lo usamos anticipando en nuestros
titulares Vamos a continuar ahora con un
repaso de lo que dicen los principales
medios por eso está con nosotros nuestra
compañera Rosa Pérez más de Rosa
bienvenida Muchas gracias Juan Rosa
vamos a comenzar este repaso ya un día
después de fallecimiento de la Reina
Isabel segunda Obviamente con la prensa
británica obviamente ese rostro de la
reina es la portada en Muchos medios
efectivamente hoy que la noticia ya está
más reposada también la encontramos Ya
en portadas en papel precisamente No
porque las rotativas ya han tenido
tiempo de imprimir el rostro de Isabel
segunda a lo largo y ancho del planeta
pero como bien decías empezamos por la
prensa británica y precisamente hemos
seleccionado cinco medios que han
elegido la misma imagen y es la imagen
de la coronación de Isabel II del 2 de
junio de 1953 en la Westminster Avi
donde tendrá lugar también su funeral y
the Times se titula una vida de servicio
mientras que de Guardian y de
independent Es simplemente
en la fecha de su nacimiento 1926 y la
de su muerte 2022 una forma también de
decir que no hay palabras para expresar
el legado no la grandeza de la figura de
esta monarca por otro lado hay también
dice destaca que Reino Unido cambió en
48 horas de Primer Ministro y de monarca
o el Daily Star que dice cumplió con su
deber mam Rosa seguimos con más prensa
británica vamos ahora concretamente con
un diario en específico el financial
Times exactamente que también destaca
esta imagen que es de 1971 y es después
de dar el discurso de apertura del año
del parlamento británico algo que
recordemos este año ya no hizo Isabel II
sino que lo hizo su hijo A pesar de que
todavía era príncipe y no rey pero que
ya era un indicio de los problemas de
salud de estas ciertas habilidades que
ella iba teniendo Isabel segunda por
otro lado tenemos el Daily mail que dice
nuestros corazones están rotos o el
Daily telegraph que cita a Isabel
segunda las palabras que pronunció
después de los atentados del 11 de
septiembre de 2001 en Estados Unidos que
dijo el Duelo es el precio que pagamos
por el amor y ahora rescatan a esta
frase en el Daily tele y de San el
periódico más leído de Reino Unido dice
te quisimos Man Rosa también es
importante que tengamos algunas portadas
que veamos ahora algunas portadas de
Irlanda del Norte y de Escocia que son
dos territorios que hacen parte del
Reino Unido pero con importantes
movimientos de independentismo
efectivamente Y por un lado de Escocia
hemos seleccionado de Herald que destaca
esta imagen con que tiene un contraste
muy interesante porque vemos a la reina
con todos estos atuendos no está digamos
construcción social un poco que es la
monarquía con todas digamos estos
vestidos delante de este paisaje tan
natural en Escocia y por otro lado
tenemos de National que se define en su
cabecera Asimismo como el periódico que
defiende una Escocia independiente y que
sin embargo hoy rinde un tributo a la
Reina Isabel segunda y lo mismo Perdón
en Irlanda del Norte no quería pasar de
largo el belfas telegraph también
gracias mam o de irish news se titula
una amiga de Irlanda varias imágenes de
distintos momentos de su vida
continuamos este repaso Rosa Ahora nos
vamos nos venimos para el continente
americano efectivamente empezamos con
New York que tampoco añade más palabras
no a esta imagen digamos tan emblemática
este dibujo por otro lado también la
revista Time que dice simplemente de
Queen La reina y por otro lado dels
beagle esta imagen esta fotografía en la
que ya parece que la monarca esté
descansando en paz y dice la última
majestad o el folio también de Italia ya
en Europa destaca esta este dibujo no de
este Guardia del Palacio de buckingham a
quienes se les atribuye ser
completamente imperturbables no y que
rompe esta Norma para digamos sollozar
por la muerte de segunda y para seguir
en Europa rápidamente repasamos otras
cabeceras como liberación de Francia que
hace como hace habitualmente juegos de
palabras y dice la pena de Inglaterra
este juego de palabras con la reina de
Inglaterra o los swag de Bélgica dice la
reina de un siglo y es que Juan Juan
Esto es algo curioso Y es que también se
atribuía a mihaela el último líder de la
unión soviética que ya era una de las
últimas figuras no que quedaban
emblemáticas del siglo 20 y que ya
desaparecía lo mismo se dice de la reina
de Inglaterra Isabel II por otro lado el
país dice un referente de las monarquías
europeas recordemos que el país es uno
de los principales periódicos también
del que es un reino el reino de España o
la República de Italia se titula la
última reina y se pregunta que queda de
la monarquía y uno de estos retos una de
las incógnitas abiertas es hasta que
punto Carlos III va a ser capaz de
mantener la popularidad de la monarquía
británica obviamente la reina presente
todas las portadas a nivel internacional
continuamos con más portadas de diarios
internacionales de nuevo en el
continente americano Exacto como como
bien decías no presentan todas las
portadas Y esto es un poco una reflejo
del alcance de su figura No es muy
destacable cuando muere pues una
personalidad ver hasta qué punto se
hacen los medios de comunicación
alrededor del mundo y vemos como con la
Reina Isabel es prácticamente unánime en
la prensa internacional como decías el
New York Times dice unió a generaciones
el Wall Street journal dice que se
mantuvo firme en una era de cambios sin
duda muchísimos cambios en el siglo XX y
también hace parece que vienen en este
Siglo 21 El Universal de México la reina
eterna o clarina de Argentina su reinado
de nuevo que marcó a fuego casi un siglo
Rosa también es importante destacar que
dice en este momento la prensa de la
commonwealth los otros 14 estados de los
cuales El Monarca británico es su jefe
de estado vamos con eso exactamente en
Canadá hemos seleccionado the glove and
the mail y the National post que también
de nuevo destacan en sus portadas a su
jefa de estado Finalmente y de National
post un poco digamos más con mejores
palabras para Isabel II dice no sirvió
con fuerza y sabiduría También tenemos a
la industria natimes de la India un país
que sufrió una violenta colonización
británica y que titula el mundo llora
cuando Reino Unido pierde su monarca más
duradera Y por último Tenemos también
Barbados today un país que Juan es
importante mencionar que formaba parte
de la monarquía británica hasta
noviembre del 2021 cuando pasó a ser una
República y por lo tanto pasó de tener
al monarca británico en ese momento
todavía Isabel segunda como jefa de
estado a tener a una presidenta que es
Sandra Manson recordemos y titula el
Barbados today Barbados se une al Duelo
adiós Reina Isabel y bien para acabar un
poco El Paso internacional el sauchain
amor impos también expresaba el duelo de
China y dijo que Isabel II había sido
Testigo Del auge y la caída de las
relaciones entre Reino Unido yin
Barbados que de manera simbólica Rihanna
como su reina nueva en segunda momento
de ver una galería de fotos sobre Isabel
II que tenemos en un medio de Rusia en
bedomostin exactamente y repasan con
instantáneas el legado y la trayectoria
de Isabel segunda una repaso que empieza
con la fotografía de su nacimiento el 21
de abril de 1926 Cuando nadie iba a
decir que se convertiría en reina No
porque recordemos no estaba prevista Si
la línea sucesoria también vemos
imágenes con Winston Churchill cuando ya
ya era jefa de estado y Winston
Churchill Primer Ministro también con
Vladimir Putin en Londres en a 2003
también con Trump y finalmente acaba
este repaso con imágenes de ayer 8 de
septiembre de 2022
de personas congregándose frente al
palacio de buckingham para rendirle
homenaje Juan es que esta mujer las ha
visto de todos los colores entre todos
los récords y Ya entrando un poco a
valorar lo que ha sido la trayectoria de
Isabel II está que vio pasar a 15
ministros primeros ministros del Reino
Unido efectivamente como decíamos no y
precisamente a raíz de la proclamación
oficial del issstras como primera
ministra que fue a balmoral a Escocia a
reunirse con la Reina Isabel el pasado 6
de septiembre esta misma semana la bbc
preparó este gráfico titulado una reina
15 primeros ministros entre los cuales
se encontrábamos como decíamos Winston
Churchill también Harold Wilson margaret
thatcher Tony Blair Boris Johnson llama
recientemente y acaba este gráfico con
listas Tenemos que hablar ahora de
margaret thatcher la Dama De Hierro
porque ella prohibición uno de los
momentos que terminó siendo terminó en
una opinión política de la reina
efectivamente fue algo muy
global no porque la reina siempre se le
ha atribuido que era ejemplar en
términos de no expresar públicamente sus
opiniones a políticas no y de mostrar
una cierta neutralidad sin embargo hubo
un hecho cuando un margaritacher estaba
al frente del gobierno británico que
llevó a la reina a comunicar su opinión
respecto a las políticas digamos del
gobierno británico y precisamente
recuperamos un artículo del New York
Times del 29 de julio de 1986 que se
titula un periódico dice que la reina
está disgustada con Tacher y dice este
artículo que la Reina Isabel II está
consternada por muchas de las políticas
de la primera ministra margaret thatcher
y los asesores Reales han tomado la
medida inusual de informar a un
periódico sobre las opiniones políticas
de la monarca quien ha sido descrita
como preocupada de que la firme
oposición de la señora Tacher a las
sanciones a Sudáfrica amanezca amenace
con romper la commonwealth y que el
gobierno británico era demasiado poco
sensible y comparecía de carecía de
compasión con los miembros menos
privilegiados de la sociedad
Muchísimas gracias por este repa